the artist ashley longshore is on quite
a roll lately
the New York Times stepped her fashions
the latest art darling a fashion editor
called longshore the Pied Piper of hope
and fun well Jamie wax has been spending
a bit of time with her to find out what
what's behind all the buzz Jamie good
morning good morning Michelle
she is as bold as the arts she makes
longshore is a sound bite machine who by
her own admission can sometimes use the
salty language of a longshoreman
she's always turning heads by doing
things her own way at the palette cafe
inside Bergdorf Goodman the department
store catering to New York's elite high
culture meets pop art you are having tea
in my brain right now the beauty level
of Bergdorf Goodman I never wanted to
lose this playfulness
if I had a tail would be wagging right
now like a little Jack Russell 40 blocks
downtown Ashleigh long shores takeover
of New York continues how did you choose
these 37 women well Diane sent me a list
at diane von fürstenberg flagship store
Malala and Jackie O and Oprah and
Michelle Obama I think the fact that
barbie is next to mother Teresa with
butterflies is Ashley longshore this one
of Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg caught the eye of another
feminist icon Gloria Steinem she's like
wow this is amazing I have to text this
to Ruth I'm like okay rvg right now a
picture of my painting it's been a
triumphant return to New York for the
brash princess of paint but her first
bite at the Big Apple was anything but
fairy tale
15 years ago I cried myself to sleep at
the Bowery Hotel I was crying so loud
that a security guard came up to see if
I was okay because I'd had an art show
and nobody bought anything and I'd spent
all my money coming up here and I was
like oh my god how am I gonna pay my
rent but you know I want to talk about
that this is about the journey that it
took me to get here back at her New
Orleans studio longshore revealed a
fuller portrait of herself instant
gratification will only get you high
pregnant or drunk everything else is
gonna take a minute you know when you
think about Sarah Ashley longshore in
Montgomery Alabama okay tell me about
her I was always very precocious one
might say I was wild very energetic
rebellious I've retired three teachers
you know but my fifth grade teacher Miss
Boswell sent me a message the other day
and was like oh my god I watched you on
Seth Meyers
all that hair you remind me of when you
were a little girl I think this was part
of my rebellious spirit that I just
didn't want to go to a Southern
University and me and another sorority
she left
Ole Miss after six weeks for a Big Sky
Country in Montana she taught herself to
paint by copying Picasso and I picked up
that brush one day which my mother never
thought I would sit still enough to
actually be a painter
I found this meditative calm that just
brought me a joy that I cannot describe
to you and I knew when I found that
whether or not I was able to figure out
how to sell these things man I found
something that brought me so much joy
over the years she developed a deeply
personal style
that's bedazzled Abraham Lincoln yes
Baberaham but all long shorts glitter
couldn't get her in the door of the
galleries so she just brushed them aside
you know I remember sitting there being
like oh but it was free you know and I
don't have any money so I'm like I got
to figure this out this would be a great
tool I think there was a day where you
did need a gallery when when you
couldn't have all these tools someone
that was curating and finding the art
collectors I mean that it is one way to
do it and I don't want to say my way is
better than their way because there's a
lot of different ways to pluck a chicken
are there this is just my way
she's leveraged the reach of social
media to promote her work with videos
like this one last month just as she had
done the day before we spoke to her in
May well the link without at 7:15 in the
morning and when I woke up at 7:48
they were completely sold out and all
the product I had hate mail
I hate mail how much does that represent
as gross sales well yesterday we did
like 1.3 million is that what you mean
yes that's what I'm yeah longshore says
she's selling her version of the
American Dream which you can buy online
or in-person at her studio and the Big
Easy longshore says she likes knowing
who her clients are they range from
celebrities to everyday walkins
paintings which can cost tens of
thousands of dollars often come with
pearls of wisdom is there one that you
feel like really captures you like
that's me in a nutshell I love work hard
eat carbs spend money I love I do not
cook I do not clean I do not fly
commercial you know I was on 7 Delta
flights last week by the way I clean up
a huge mess in my kitchen this morning
and yes and I made Sanaa boto so I do
cook I do clean I do fly commercial but
I think you know these mantras these
things words are powerful you know and
it's funny and it's fun her work which
combines art and commerce has frequently
been compared to the legendary pop
artist Andy Warhol a comparison
longshore finds humbling I always say I
want to have a career like Andy Warhol
and I'm gonna have a legacy like Peggy
Guggenheim in fact longshore says the
plan is to start a foundation to bring
Ashley world as she calls it to everyone
I'm gonna have a massive building full
of all of this art I want the public to
be able to enjoy it I want to give
scholarships to kids that are interested
in the arts this isn't all about 1.3
million dollars or two commas in the
bank this is about so much bigger than
that it's a feeling you know it's it's a
it's a feeling of the American dream man
is she fun long short credits her father
Spencer for her incredible work ethic
which is on full display this year with
a coffee table book coming out in
October a newly announced global
cosmetics collaboration with Maybelline
launching during New York Fashion Week
and the second extension of that
exhibited Diane von Furstenberg keeping
that show open to the public through the
end of the year
she is a girl after my own heart
absolutely love her I'm fat hungry at
Matty's house that's the one I want yeah
it is so fun just to walk around her
gallery and look at the sayings that
she's come up with on those walls it
offers this art to so many people the
way she does it without needing to have
that broker yeah yes it's a bit too
game-changer called New Orleans home
Ashley world yeah